happy holidays merry christmas
very merry and you're jewish happy
harmonica
okay okay that's it it's go time let's
go chuck throw me the ball
all right yeah me and you y'all let's go
that is a super choice
would you like any signs
i need your address now
tell them to send it to shakira brah
wait you're shakira
yeah don't twice i wanna pizza slice can
you get it to me boy
i understand brother
this is a tough one for me seth
because i've known the man for 10 years
lebron
i know you want to be a good teammate
but in the fourth quarter of the miami
basketball contest
only one man
should be holding the basketball
i want to play a clip of keenan hosting
this show
on saturday night live
today in your health we talking about
overcoming full buyers now everybody got
some kind of a fo buyer and we get
excuse me
what is it
oh phobias
phobias you think that you're scared of
phobia now look at him people got all
kind of phobias
ain't no reason to judge anybody you see
i got this thing where i'm scared that
after i fall asleep my mustache gonna
slide down my throat and choke me to
death he did that on the show yeah how
to knock your ass out
for bias damn sure what i would say
though cause
everybody got a full buyer man i also
liked if it bleeds we can kill it
if it please exactly if you please we
can kill it yeah
i mean does he need some more tips on
how to get the accent absolutely right
i i think he's doing a great job i mean
it makes me laugh and that's the bottom
line you know to entertain
you more you want to get down
get down
come with me if you want to live
[Laughter]
do it
just do it yeah consider this a divorce
remember
in total recall yeah when they when they
shot sharon stone through the head yeah
and what about
get to mars
just the last one to finish um arnie
because uh because i have a hundred of
them but this is a particularly good one
from again predator
harper they didn't disappear he was
skinned alive
very good
very good i love you man just a few
weeks ago a comedian named matthew
friend did an impression of you on our
show i want you to watch it and then
assess
well what you need to understand alex is
i am so glad to be here right now
because i am indoors with no one around
me so i can finally have my mask off my
face i can breathe again more and more
people should be wearing masks as you
know
so so what do you make of that
you did a great job alex
you do know that uh the the other night
uh maybe a week ago
jeff the robot here did uh a morgan
freeman voice all night did he yeah i
don't i don't know how does it sound
like morgan well i think maybe if he
could if we could talk a minute doing it
a little bit now you could maybe judge
it do you mind no i don't i'm not well
let's see
would you like to hear my morgan freeman
boys
[Applause]
see when i open my mouth it makes
everything sound smart
that's outstanding yeah it's outstanding
it's very very good first time i've ever
heard myself from the outside
yeah there there's through the wormhole
keyhole right there
i'll freak you out that would that would
yeah
what do you want to say to yourself
yeah what would you i don't know think
of something nice
all right
let's talk about craig ferguson
go ahead i dare you
damn you look good
jeff is very intense
in a good way
oh yes
well i i do believe um yes
yes
really
i would love to see that
wow that's good i didn't know he had
that uh
up his sleeve as he says it's intense
and he made those big eyes once how is
this
you gotta put the pizza
back in the oven
it's not cooked i mean look at it the
green pepper the mushroom the onions he
got my finger thing
i've always felt like i have a
high-pitched voice when i perform
and this [ __ ] just nailed the
kind of like the cry hussein voice i
know you're like hustle 24 minutes shut
the [ __ ] up
oh no he's doing the thing
i can't even wait 20 more seconds
but whether we like it or not do i
really just pivot like this
do i really do there's a more
fundamental problem
papa john
[ __ ] up our order i'm not gonna lie to
you
now he's pulling me in like i wanna know
how papa john's systematically [ __ ] up
the pizza delivery business
[Music]
[Music]
you see that look that chuck has given
me over there that i hope it doesn't
break into my voice that's gonna be nuts
he does not sound like me it looks like
a fool can i tell him he's crazy i'm
just waiting
all right that's how bad stuff happened
around here
you know it's been really fun watching
all your promos
but i'm not going to be happy they say
you do me really well
he's been he's doing that
that's the problem
i'm listening right now but i don't hear
what is going with it just doesn't sound
it doesn't sound right that guy's a
knucklehead i don't know what he's
thinking you know what he's saying let
me tell you something hold on a second i
never get to finish anything here i
start to say something everybody takes
it away from me how come i can't finish
a sentence in this place what's what's
the problem here
that's not bad
hold on a second
give me the camera who what where's my
camera take a look stop if you're gonna
switch cameras let me know okay don't
make me look like an idiot over here all
right chris bar should be nowhere near a
basketball
he should be locked in a small closet
where there are no basketballs around
objects of any kind
mario chalmers should not be allowed to
have arms to shoot at basketball
well it was it was hysterical first of
all i appreciate it but i would never
wear that suit i would never wear that
i would never wear that shirt with that
tie you know the shirt and the tie
combination he could have done a better
job my style is a little bit more
pristine than that got a couple of
seconds go ahead do it let me see it
just a little just a little or is that
just a little you know what i'm talking
about just let me see a little
[Applause]
not so easy when i'm sitting right here
is it big shot
there we go okay here we go i'm not
ready for this i don't know i know
you're not ready now no
you're ready on your little show but
you're not ready here
you got all week to get ready on your
little show
oh yeah here we go so it's like uh
who's going to be there i don't know rob
lowe rob lowe and the spice girls
do you enjoy the you enjoy the spice
girls pal nice girl spice girls yeah
yeah yeah well they'll they'll be on the
show
and uh paul do you you watch the
saturday night live show
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what time is
that on now paul
i say what what time would that be on
it's like uh 11 that's live yeah
oh